gets the rebound that was a much better
close
by eight hookers sees some room
baseline jumper rolls off the rim ball's
still alive
knocked loose picked up by canard lost
it there and a foul from behind
as beverly knocks down deandre ayton
and that'll be a playground i don't
think so i don't think that's a flagrant
foul you got a big guy under the rim
going to duncan i'll tell you you know
how screwed up the rule is
is if we could never agree i say no you
say yes
you say yes i say no this one looked
obvious
to me wind-up impact follow-through
that's a wind-up to stop him from
dunking it that's not a flag or foul to
me
wind up but hitting on the head i think
that's going to go flare on one mark
i don't think that's a flavor he got the
ball first i'll say that for
your case windup and impact you know
what's messed up if you were over there
as his coach you'd be like great job
great job that's playoff basketball
i i agree with you but you're
you're so strange on all this a guy gets
love
tapped in the face on a jump shot and
you think a a crime has been committed
and now down at this end a guy takes a
wind up and
slams the guy probably has a concussion
now
and you're good with that you you have
like
you make no sense though you should be
the last person
on earth to call me strangers no you're
right about that
all right let's check in with our man
steve javy once again come on steve
side with me at least once in your life
i'll tell you one thing i'm just
enjoying you guys going back and forth
with each other i love this this is
wonderful
well i really believe now this in my
opinion anyway you do have the wind up
the impact he does have the ball but he
hits him upside the head there so
it's the severity of contact and where
the contact occurs
and i think in my opinion this would be
a flagrant one because of the wind up
and then him hitting in the head
it's going to be beverly's second foul
regardless whether it's a common foul or
the flagrant
you know the wind up hits the basketball
first so he's winding up to block a big
guy's dump
you're right you're reeling me back into
your side now
i don't know where i lost my mind now
i'm thinking everything's a flagrant
foul oh
thank you to steve javie once again
meanwhile eight and off to a good start
here in the first half ten points
five rebounds mark davis the crew chief
taking a long look at it
it's gonna be a call to play we're gonna
foul whether we agree or not
it's just how it is
it appears he's come to a conclusion
here we it's a replay that's determined
this file to be a common file we have
two free throws you are on a roll
y'all fly steve jabbing here and fly me
to see caucus man
all ball see it's not all ball it's a
foul
but he did block it
[Music]
beverly now explaining it to devin
booker who has
zero interest in listening to him right
now
do you think the referee the referees
decide that right
yes but most of the replay is decided
back in c
caucus and the referees are just sort of
there too
he's not being enticed into the back and
forth
and we've seen historically great
players get enticed with the back and
forth
ayton misses a pair